TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update
about the coolest developer
news from Google in
the last two weeks.
Android Things
developer preview 6.1
has API support for
configuring and managing
low power, wireless,
personal area network,
including first class
networking support for threat.
These types of
connectivity solutions
enable Android Things devices
to perform edge computing tasks,
aggregating data locally
from nearby devices
to make critical decisions
without a constant connection
to cloud services.
Links to get started are on the
post linked in the description
below.
The M20 release of the Flutter
plug-in for Android Studio
and IntelliJ is now available.
Fixes and improvements
are listed on the post.
Our OAuth API
access controls now
let you control access to
Google Cloud Platform resources
in addition to your
users G-suite data.
Details and screenshots
are on the post.
To help you do
more with ML, we've
adjusted our prices for
cloud machine learning engine
and added new features,
including Python and TensorFlow
updates.
More details are on the post.
We've also been
expanding our portfolio
of pre-trained machine
learning models
to offer more
intuitive features.
Cloud Video
Intelligence, our machine
learning API that analyzes video
content, is generally available
and now offers
video transcription.
Cloud Natural Language
Content Classification,
our latest feature, which
automatically classifies
content in over 700 categories,
is now generally available
and has added additional samples
in seven programming languages.
You can now deploy TensorFlow
models with core ML on iOS.
Links to the documentation
and the core ML converter
are on the post.
Hangouts Meet is now accessible
through the Google Calendar API
to read conference data
associated with events,
copy conference data from
one event to another,
and request new conference
generation for an event.
Example code is on the post.
We built an iOS
game with Firebase,
and the Unity Project
is open source.
Take a look at the post to learn
more about the Firebase Unity
SDK and how it's
used in MechaHamster.
The graphics API
debugger is a new tool
that helps you diagnose
rendering and performance
issues with your applications.
With it, you can capture a trace
of your application and step
through each graphics
command one by one.
Take a look at the post for
screenshots and the download
link.
The S2 library is the
core geometric library
on which Google's global
geographic database is built,
and now it's open source.
Take a look at the post for
a description and the GitHub
link.
Please like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching
this week's TLDR.
If you'd like to catch
some earlier updates
or get the inside scoop from GDD
India, click right over here.